[Music]  kangokuma is an architect but he isn't  just any architect he is a master at his  [Music]  craft a clear ethos kengo has a knack  for doing things that run counter to  20th century established design norms  [Music]  is  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  and that philosophy has made kengo and  his over 200 designs stand out from the  high-rise crowd  [Music]  in addition to sustainability kengo has  found that utilizing natural materials  has practical advantages  [Music]  is  [Music]  working with sustainable materials  doesn't hinder kengo's work  he works on buildings of all shapes and  sizes  [Music]  have been tasked to construct the new  national stadium which will be used for  the 2020 summer olympics in japan  [Music]  hopes that his mastery of architecture  will help the world think differently  about urban spaces  [Music]  foreign yeah  [Music]